so real quickly about my background
studied here 2004 to 2006 and focused
mostly on agriculture in the environment
then my house almost burned down in
Australia when I moved there and lent I
ended up in Washington DC with World
Wildlife Fund I've been there ever since
so it's about six and a half years now
and I spend most of my time working with
the private sector in developing field
programs and multi-stakeholder based
standards specifically bonsu crow
formerly known as a better sugarcane
initiative I'm on the board of directors
of bumsoo Crow and have been there for
the last three years two of which I
served as chairman and worked with
companies ranging from the coca-cola
company to Bacardi to pepsico Shell BP
and then producers around the world of
sugar cane so we can keep this talk
pretty informal today and so if I'll
have probably about 30 40 minutes of
straight type slides but if you have any
burning questions in the middle feel
free to raise your hand and we can have
a discussion so now has anyone ever been
to a sugarcane mill before where was
your wares sugarcane mill ooh which one
Casa de Campo around there okay no you
don't need to apologize there are a
couple down there but basically when you
think about sugarcane the mill is the
epicenter of there and this is a
Brazilian mill and so it's a little
different from the other Mills that
you'll find in the world and that
there's a lot of ethanol that goes on in
Brazil and half of the canaan Brazil
goes into ethanol and a lot of that
ethanol actually ends up in the u.s.
right now under the renewable fuel
standards to by the EPA and the
important thing about the mill is that
it's basically the center of a radius
you have about 60 to 100 kilometers
around sometimes
a little bit more of sourcing area of
sugarcane so you generally have a
relatively concentrated area of
production which means you have a
generally relative relatively
concentrated area of impact now you
might think to yourself why why WWF and
sugarcane oh we're conservation
organization last week my boss was here
Dave jolly guy with the glasses talking
about palm oil many of the same things
we're concerned about habitat use or
habitat conversion as well as runoff
greenhouse gas emissions and other
impacts on the environment as well as
people now some quick facts about
sugarcane there are about 24 million
hectares around the world planted the
sugarcane over half the industry is in
Brazil and half the production is in
Brazil and you're looking at about one
hundred and seventy four million tons of
sugar is produced a year and that's
that's sugar cane and beet it's hard to
differentiate between the two when you
get the aggregate numbers but about 80%
of sugar around the world is from cane
twenty percent is from sugar beet in the
u.s. we produce both in Europe it's all
beat the US it's about fifty-fifty split
and the big issues around sugar cane
from a WWF standpoint are that it occurs
in our priority areas so every red arrow
on that slide is a WWF priority
ecoregion and that has sugar cane it now
WWF globally has 30 or so priority
ecoregions 35 it changes every year
depending on who's making what decisions
and that's that's the joy of working in
a multinational organization but for
sugar cane the big issues are direct and
indirect land-use change as well as
impacts on fresh water quality which
we'll talk about in a bit especially on
marine habitats like coral reefs and on
top of that water use sugar cane is an
extremely thirsty
it is a c4 crop in that it processes
carbon through the c4 pathway much like
corn in the US and then there are also
impacts in terms of greenhouse gas
emissions half of the greenhouse gas gas
is emitted for sugarcane production come
from burning the cane before you harvest
it now you burn the cane before you
harvest it if you are in a generally
manual harvesting system where people
walk in into the cane fields with
machetes and hack away all day it's not
a fun job but it provides a lot of
employment for a lot of people around
the world additionally WWF sees
sugarcane as a part of global solutions
in that it produces both ethanol and bio
lecture citty in Brazil you're talking
three to four percent of the total
electricity produced in that country is
from ethanol or is from from a sugarcane
male at that sugar plant they're burning
the gas which is that that big pile of
fiber fifteen percent of the sugarcane
plant is fiber and they burn that in a
boiler creates electricity and they sell
it onto the grid so we see it as a
solution in terms of clean energy at for
the electricity grid as well as clean
energy for your cars and now they're
developing new solutions where sugarcane
can be used for diesel as well as jet
fuel and plastics so has anyone seen
coca-cola's plant bottle that's made
from sugarcane thirty percent eventually
it will be one hundred percent sugarcane
or other plant feedstock as well as
recycled material now sure
yes yeah no it'll all be through normal
recycling they've yeah they've totally
they've engineered it to be exactly like
that and WWF works on sugarcane in a
number of ways we work with companies in
a bilateral arrangement we lobby on
policy for sugarcane especially ethanol
and then we also work to develop field
programs and today i will talk mostly
about field programs and next week we'll
have a panel discussion to talk about
developing global standards the three
projects that i'll talk about today our
project catalyst in queensland australia
project Kula kula is Zulu for grow
that's in South Africa and then project
restore that's in Sao Paulo Brazil has
anyone been to any of these three places
before no all right so it's like we're
going on a tour together that is a blank
slide so real quick the reason why we
were just talking about giving
presentations so another reason why WWF
is concerned is here are some quick
facts looking forward so in the future
we're going to have almost fifty percent
area increase just to meet sugar demand
alone because as people become more
affluent they eat more sugar in India
for instance sugar has two prices one
for poor people because it's a human
right and the other is for everyone else
so you have significant demand around
the world and there there is a lot of
interplay and a lot of writing about how
sugars played an important role in the
industrial revolution and a number of
other time periods and countries in
terms of providing those moments of
short-term pleasure to keep people happy
um it's somewhat miserable lives like
working in a factory in terms of WWF's
ecoregions we're seeing expansion and co
police Africa and the Mekong and we
anticipate that there will be
significant expansion in Brazil in parts
of Southeast Asia in Indonesia and Papua
New Guinea as well as other parts of
africa and mexico both to meet the
demands of sugar as well as ethanol so
project catalyst here we have basically
one of the flattest parts of the eastern
seaboard of australia called the
burdekin and it's the sea of sugarcane
all along the coast and right next to it
on this coast is the Great Barrier Reef
you can kind of see the islands than
that and the not only up the islands but
also the coral reef structures
themselves now some quick facts about
the Australian sugarcane industry I
won't read them to you but just know
that Australia is the third-largest
trader of sugar in the world and that
this is about a three billion four
billion dollar industry for the
Australians and it's experiencing a lot
of transition right now farmers are
getting old in fact one of one of the
growers who we work with down there said
if you want to save the Great Barrier
Reef hold 3,000 funerals but that's not
necessarily the way we want to go now
some of the challenges oh can you guys
see the words sorry it's kind of white
on blue background here all right sweet
so the Great Barrier Reef does anyone
know what that is all right it's the
world's largest living structure pretty
amazing if you go there and from an
economic standpoint you're looking at a
multibillion-dollar industry for people
in Australia providing employment for
65,000 people up and down the coast in
terms of tourism outfits as well as you
get your multiplier effect additionally
the Great Barrier Reef is 2,900
individual structures that connected
create this fascinating sort of 3d
multi-dimensional ecosystem now the reef
is under threat from 22 things mainly
there's a third but it's not as
significant the biggest impact is
climate change and coral bleaching
that's the biggest long-term threat the
most immediate impact is from
terrestrially based runoff and that's
that comes from sugarcane production and
cattle production and a little bit from
the horticultural sector thirty percent
of the runoff is from sugarcane about
seventy percent just under seventy
percent of the runoff and nutrients are
from cattle and we know that if we
reduce that run off to a level that's
acceptable then we can save the reef in
the face of climate change there there's
recent research that's come out showing
that the coral assemblage will change
coral species will be different but we
can save the reef now these are just
some pictures illustrating runoff so
we're dealing with an event-based
ecosystem you get heavy rainfalls it
it's like it's a giant flush just takes
everything out you can see that from
space you've got all that all that
nutrient sediment coming out and you can
see the inner reef shelves or r33 sort
of reef layers going out east end of the
Coral Sea now here's healthy reef
pictures and here are not so healthy
reef pictures will just do this one more
time sediment algal outbreaks as well as
outbreaks of the crown-of-thorns
starfish which feed on corals
crown-of-thorns starfish outbreaks come
right after heavy events high
correlation between runoff of nitrogen
and crown of thorns starfish outbreaks
now we also know
that sugarcane farmers waste a lot of
nitrogen fertilizer they probably about
60 percent of what they put on ends up
out on the reef so not only is that bad
for the environment it's also bad for
these farmers because it's in the top
two or three costs of production and
most of these farms the majority do not
actually make money from farming urine
and year out they get off farm income to
maintain their farms now one of the
answers to this is precision agriculture
but there are significant barriers to
adopting precision agriculture and
there's been some research lately of why
farmers aren't adopting it because we
think Oh win win win win situation but
you're talking about a cross section of
the population that's over 60 slow to
adapt new technologies risk-averse
because it's all they have and so the
government has created a fund for 150
million dollars to actually transition
farmers from their old practices to new
practices that are less impactful on the
reef now we at WWF and our partners on
the ground are taking that a step
further because the government program
called reef rescue is only taking
farmers from the 1960s to the 1980s or
90s in terms of technology we want to
take them to the next century so we've
developed project catalyst and project
catalyst is a multi-stakeholder process
and project on the ground where we bring
together government agencies individual
farmers as well as extension officers
now extension is expensive in Australia
people are very expensive in Australia
to hire health care the cost of fuel
everything is expensive so what we do is
we provide sort of a safe space for
farmers to get together and get new
extension ideas in and work on creating
precision agriculture plans for each
farm and this this is what one of those
plans looks like we're
you have someone come out and spend a
couple of days with you you do soil
tests you do you look at the yields and
then you figure out what's the best way
to improve productivity on your farm
while reducing the inputs and so to date
and that we've been going on this for
about five years we've reduced annual
runoff by 84 tons of particulate
nitrogen 75 tons of dissolved inorganic
nitrogen and nitrogen is our real target
here we also want to reduce pesticides
but nitrogen is the big one so we now
have reached six percent of the industry
and we continue to expand our our
impacts additionally and this is one of
the things that's most exciting about it
is that farmers have started to look
over their fence and start imitating and
emulating what project catalyst growers
are doing and so we're getting a
knock-on ripple effect there now a lot
of that I was asked to talk a lot about
precision agriculture and when I think
about precision agriculture you have to
find out find ways of doing precision
agriculture that fits the region because
not everyone's going to have half a
million dollars like these farmers due
to buy a harvester or to buy equipment
that will run your tractors through
global information system or global
positioning systems so we also have a
program in South Africa called Project
Kula and project Kula really focuses on
developing improved management practices
for farms that are much smaller and for
people who don't have as much capital
these are Zulu farmers in the eastern
area of South Africa and to date we've
reached about six hundred farmers of a
total of twenty-seven thousand and by
2020 we intend to to meet the needs of
20,000 farmers and our big focus with
project Kula is to create a mentorship
where you bring together government
tension officers and professional
farmers they call them essentially
they're the white farmers in South
Africa there are about fifteen hundred
of them and they create an information
exchange with the Zulu farmers and we
provide trainings and a number of
activities for them but before going too
much further the South African sugarcane
industry is much smaller than Australia
it's much smaller than Brazil as we'll
talk about later and it has a number of
challenges of its own and one of the
major reasons why project Kula exists is
because we need to find ways of
improving relationships between the
relatively impoverished black South
Africans mostly Zulu in this area as
well as the relatively wealthy white
South Africans who in the region where
project cool is our German descendants
whereas in the rest of the industry
they're relatively of Afrikaans
descendants just an origin anyway the
other issues that are facing industry
are decreasing production as you can see
by this graph since in the last 10 or 12
years you've gone from 2.6 million tons
of sugar per year to 1.8 million oh this
most recent dip is due to a huge drought
and it should be back up to 2.1 million
tons a year but really you're seeing a
decrease in production and you're seeing
an increase in urbanization of the
sugarcane production areas not
necessarily something we want to see
because we're coming up on an election
in South Africa that they tend to be you
know very controversial in this area
because of historical issues and so
project kula also seeks to build and
improve livelihoods so that you can
avoid some of the political violence
that's occurred in the past the other
major issue that project kula looks at
is improving water water flows and
rivers and assuring that there's water
for people there's a report out a few
days ago saying
estimating that by 2025 South Africa
will be out of water that's a bit of an
exaggeration but it in some areas it
will become a very water-scarce country
so this is a a ranking of the degrees of
water stress and for all the mainstem
rivers and project kula is sort of let's
see it's right along that orange and
yellow area right before you get some
the deep red so it's a relatively
water-stressed area and much of the
water stress in South Africa is not only
from use for agriculture but also the
presence of invasive species so again in
project Kula we're trying to develop
jobs and one of those development
programs is hiring people to clear
invasive species and increase stream
water flow now going back to the main
purpose of project Kula which is to
improve sugar cane farming here we have
one of the team of project Kula
participant the big white guy in the
back his name is Jurgen the Zulus call
him big show because Zulus love
wrestling they seriously watch a lot of
WWE and they're big fans of it so they
call him big show then you have a
government extension agent next to him
in the green and white shirt his name is
good enough and then you have a number
of other people who are involved in the
project they're standing in a soil pit
and one of the first steps of this
program is to work with the farmers to
get them to understand the potential of
their land in that they go out the
farmers typically go out and plant
sugarcane without the best agronomic
practices and without understanding
where to plant it and how to plant it
and what they're sitting on right now is
some of the best soil in the country
it's better than the white farmers have
then we develop we developed terraces so
that they're no longer
planting with the topography rather than
against it this improves yield as well
as improving the the overall management
of the landscape so that water flows off
appropriately within project Kula we
deliver the following things we deliver
seed cane nurseries now this is
important because it provides the
sugarcane growers with their own source
of seed so that they don't have to buy
it from the mill or from other people
keeps more income in the in the
community provide a number of trainings
from pest management to planting
techniques to soil management and we
also provide jobs through invasive
control through working for water
additionally it provides a new sense of
community you know in addition to
increasing your yields by from about 30
tons to 120 tons per hectare and all the
multiplier effects that that come with
it you bring together people to work
together in a way that they haven't done
in quite some time and right here in the
woman in red she's the president of the
most successful cooperative and which is
very uncommon in Zulu society because
it's a very patriarchal society you've
got chiefs and everything but she calls
all the shots and and really brings the
community together make sure that the
money that they make from sugar cane
farming gets reinvested in terms of
developing the community they provide
they buy new school uniforms they also
bring in doctors every month or two for
check-ups now this is the last project
i'll talk about before we open it up and
this is called project restore this is
new asst project with the sugar cane
industry and it's one that we're really
excited about and it's based in Brazil
we've got five major focal points for
this project one is to increase bond
sucrose certification two is to organize
farmers and implement better management
practices and we'll link restore with
project catalyst to to really
drive home how farmers facing similar
issues around the world can help each
other three restore forests in brazil
the atlantic forest is the most
biodiverse area in the world and i'll
talk about that in a minute it's also
one of the most endangered and then
we'll focus on climate protection by
increasing the amount of bioelectricity
produce at the mill level and then will
model the value of nature and create
different scenarios for Cain expansion
as the industry doubles over the next 10
or so years so Brazilian sugarcane in
the state of são Paulo this is half of
the industry in one state alone this is
a map all the red is where the sugarcane
is produced and the green is the Amazon
Brown is the Pantanal so not a lot of
direct impact but there's some indirect
impact of sugarcane expansion on the
Amazon and other places relatively low
water stress on the industry because
it's not on the rivers because it's not
irrigated most of the water impacts are
from water pollution and a relatively
low amount of fertilizer applied you're
looking at 60 kilograms per hectare
versus in Australia do you remember on
the previous slide 150 kilograms and not
that much difference in yield now the
Atlantic forest one of the most
biodiverse places on earth one to eight
percent of all species and and through a
number of different sort of sub
ecosystems there is less than eleven
percent remaining and it used to span
from Paraguay all the way up to the
Northeast of Brazil the deforestation
rate I left that off it's something
you'll have to look up it's actually
about less than one percent a year but
still significant because there's very
little left and only 1.6 two percent is
under protective status this graph here
demonstrates what used to be in red and
what is left in green by state in Brazil
so you can see a very small percentage
in the state of são Paulo has left
excuse me
here is a map of the historic range of
the Atlantic forest and what's left the
dark spots are what's left the light
gray is the historic range so it's a
pretty decimated area largely converted
for agriculture excuse me now the first
step in project restore is really
focused on getting farmer buy-in to
improving and restoring the landscape
now you can't go in and work with the
farmer and say I want you to take ten
percent of your area out of production
and plant trees without giving them some
type of benefit so we are linking them
to funding and to other ideas to improve
their practices the Brazil is largely
seen as the leading sugar cane producer
in the world but as you'll see almost
anywhere there's room for improvement
here's a picture of some sugar cane
farms in Brazil these are problematic
because if there's water like that
standing you can't grow sugarcane in
recent years they've had to leave as
much as a million tons or a million
hectares unharvested because of poor
water management on their farms so when
you have this you lose a lot of money
and you'll need more area to produce
then you'll also have situations like
this where you'll have washouts and when
you lose your soil you lose your
productive base so one of our ideas and
that we're developing is again going
back to precision agriculture
understanding the way the landscape
works and how to work with it and
developing flow ways for the water to go
so you go from this and this and then
you manage it and set up the production
areas so that you get natural flow waves
and don't have that water logging don't
have standing water can increase yields
increase profitability after we begin to
work with farmers like that it's our
theory that will
have the a more hospitable group of
people to work with and then we'll be
able to work with them on restoring the
Atlantic forest and the sehat o as well
we're going to do this through a number
of mechanisms one organizing the entire
industry to really deliver change at
scale our goal is to get about 150
thousand hectares with the industry over
the next few years over the next 20
years Brazil is going to have to restore
bylaw 20 million hectares and they have
to do that every individual landholder
has to do that and every two years they
have to report on how they're how
they're doing it and how their ten
percent closer than they were two years
earlier so the car the the key mechanism
will be working with under the forest
code is called the car that's cadastral
I'm being tailed rural the rural
registry of land and we'll be working
with them to map out specifically where
people should restore lands and how you
can how to replant and working with
farmers to develop nurseries and taking
people who used to have jobs cutting
cane which is not a fun job you're out
there in 90-degree heat all day little
protection from the Sun cutting cane and
we want to give them new jobs managing
nurseries and managing plantations and
WWF has developed a map for the state of
são paulo as to our priorities for where
we want to work this is that map and the
black areas the black outline Darius are
our priority areas the green is the
remnant vegetation and protect areas and
then the light purple is all the sugar
king so we have a lot of work to do and
as we progress will be undertaking a
monitoring and evaluation system and to
verify that farmers are doing what they
agree to and concurrently we'll be
working with the universities to model
out how the industry can expand without
doing what they did in the past in terms
of impacting biodiversity and
we'll be working with academic and
private sector interests as well as
other NGOs like the Nature Conservancy
here are our macro goals for engaging
with the sugarcane industry and over the
next couple of years we'll be bringing
people on board to create this large
sustainability platform right now we've
got about two or three milling groups on
board and over the next couple of weeks
we anticipate we'll have a number of
others so with that I hope that I've
relaid just some of the different ways
and situations that you have to work
with people around the world because of
their different economic situations in
the different environmental situations
that that are impacted by sugarcane and
will open up for questions and
conversation so now the with the
sugarcane industry there are only 16 er
Suri's in the state of são Paulo that's
a major log jam additionally the
sugarcane industry is transitioning from
burning to not burning and that's going
to be about 250,000 people out of jobs
so one of their goals is to also find
new jobs and this will be one source for
them to work there's also a low success
rate of restoration success so we will
hopefully increase that oh you mean okay
in terms of South Africa with the seed
banks there are companies that are doing
seed that do sugarcane seed production
but sugar canes sort of an understudied
crop versus soy or corn there aren't
that many it's developed by locally by
research institutions
mmm and Brazil around the world it
depends on the place like in India they
don't burn sugar cane and they're the
second largest producer of cane no
they're starting to because of labor
shortages but they don't burn for two
reasons one their sugarcane fields are
little one hectare to hectare plots and
they're surrounded by other crops so
they don't want the fire to get out of
control and burn their neighbors cotton
the other reason is everybody owns
cattle there and dairy cows so they feed
the what what gets burned to their their
cows and then in places like it buries
uh they're trying to phase it out in
certain countries and in others they're
not so but it's it's a major issue for
sure
yeah that's why we were setting up this
monitoring system around making sure
that people are doing it